hi and welcome to episode number 40 of
the wiggly Google cloud platform podcast
i am francisco and i'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good I'm back yeah welcome
back as a short hiatus I I was very sad
I was fur had to be gone but I'm glad to
be back now I was it was good i got a
different australian you know i could
even I could not even tell the
difference really so yeah don't worry
don't worry you can you can live again
this one guy changes as good as a
holiday I guess yeah we have many
Australians to replace you so it's fine
ah good to know that I'm loved in an
island and I'm very very happy you liked
so today we're gonna have an interview
with someone that works for rodeo FX
yeah really cool company that does
really cool stuff it is a pre amazing
company I've seen a couple videos of
their demos and basically they do they
do visual visual effects special effects
for you know some people that you may
have heard about like I don't know Game
of Thrones maybe you've heard about it
Deadpool yeah you know like it is pretty
amazing and there's a couple videos will
put the links on the on the show notes
as usual and this time I really
recommend you to go check them out
because they're they're pre amazing
awesome they're awesome and after that
we'll end up as usual with the question
of the week and the question of the week
today is about it's something that you
actually came up with yeah well I I
can't take credit it was from the slack
community we were talking about on
they're talking about compute engine is
nas's how to create an instant group
from an already existing Google compute
engine virtual machine cool that is
actually something I've done before yeah
yeah it is it is fun I've done it before
because I helped someone do it so yes it
was a good time cool so yeah we'll talk
about that at the end of the episode and
now we are going to talk about the cool
thing of the week yeah and as actually
it starts to be like as usual it is not
one cool thing of the week but a bunch
of them there are too many cool things
yeah there's too many cool things we
need we need more episode maybe we
should do this episode
the episode daily don't don't no no no I
think it's I think we find so yeah we
have we have three products that are now
generally available so they're out of
beta and you can now use them with SL
A's and all that stuff so we have cloud
sequel Club big table and cloud
datastore so three different ways of
storing data which is pretty amazing
yeah so just be clear as well so that's
cloud sequel the second generation yeah
which has way more power on the first
one hugely hugely cool it is incredibly
fast yeah incredibly incredibly fast and
cloud datastore which I mean that's been
around for a while but is now generally
available to everything outside of
adventure yeah the i think is the rest
api that is because if you were using it
from App Engine it was already general
available from long time ago but now if
you're using it from outside of it the
API itself is not generally available
term which is cool and big table is just
well let's big table it's always been
really great big dick was amazing it is
it is really big really big yeah and on
the other side there's also a bunch of
different things that we're going to
link to this but there's one more thing
that I wanted to mention because I was
actually really impressed which is a
Google Cloud storage near line it is
much faster than before so quick
overview Google Cloud storage near line
where you want to like archive long time
data probably not going to touch it very
often like monthly logs back cups and
stuff like that that you don't really
care about them until your care about
them yeah and then I thought that you
will get like yeah I want the backup
from like a year ago you want it to be
there really yep so yeah like I think
the technical name is in frequently
accessed data yeah and normally there's
you know there's competitors that
proposed things like this and it takes
couple hours to retrieve that data from
the beginning Google proposed a solution
was like couple minutes is that then we
went down to seconds that's bit better
and now it is as fast as normal cloud
storage it seems just right yeah which
is promising this is really fast so it's
like I could say it's probably around
like couple hundred milliseconds so yeah
so as soon as you want that data is as
soon as you're getting that data yeah
that date is there so that is pretty
missing
and I was so impressed that I decided to
talk about it today but there's many
other things so go check it out we have
a link to one announcement with a bunch
of new things that happened this week
fantastic awesome well why don't we go
have a chat with allen and hear all
about visual effects in google cloud
platform sounds good let's go with that
we are joined today by a gentleman named
Alan Friedman from rodeo FX how you
doing today Alan hello thank you so much
for joining us on the podcast you want
to tell us a little bit about who you
are and what you do it radio effects so
my name is Alan I'm a pipeline developer
at rodeo FX the company has been around
for about 10 years and I've been there
for four and it's grown a lot since I've
been there I initially started as what's
known as a rigger which is this the guy
who articulates the characters or
vehicles or such and slowly in the last
couple of years I've been doing more of
a developer role doing more coding
mostly Python and it's really exciting
the studio has grown from like 50 people
to like 300 and something in in a couple
of years and it's crazy so I could get a
bit of an inkling from the name of the
company but what exactly does it do yeah
so we do a visual effects for film and
high-end TV series we've done some work
for the last three seasons of Game of
Thrones and duck is little commercial
but mostly film we did some work on the
last star treks and some work on
Deadpool Birdman the last Tarzan
fantastic beasts which is about to come
out soon lots of creatures and that one
really exciting and some old stuff like
Pacific Rim and hedges tomorrow old
stuff yeah yeah then yes and it seems
all the line I my timeline now that
those are awesome so when you describe
yourself you use the term pipeline
developer yeah what what is what is that
exactly a pipeline in my industry it's
basically the sort of flow of data from
one one specialty to another so to speak
so there's
a lot of specialties in the visual
effects you can really not it's really
hard to be a one-man shop you really get
I specialize in and if it goes through
like modeling texturing shading anime
rigging animation lighting and layout
and eventually compositing and to get
everything to be version than to flow
and to import and export and and all the
statuses of everything and everything to
be out of up to date and correct and
valid and follow convention there's this
term of the pipeline which is basically
sort of the the conglomeration of tools
is kind of like if the tools were
neurons in the brain that the mind will
be the pipeline is sort of like the
abstract all-encompassing concept and a
pipeline developer basically works
towards making the the flow of the
information smooth cool so could you
tell us a little bit about what kind of
tools or what kind of products used to
make these happen specifically a google
score in general 9 in general like what
kind of like what is gout is the process
look like like somebody comes to you and
they're like hey we want this scene shot
in a movie like where it is how does
that how does that look so initially
there's a bidding process where Studios
say how how much they will cost to do a
particular shot and it's up to the
client to decide who to give what to
based on the reputation and their
funding and suppose once you we get a
shot and it's confirmed the we we
usually receive the plates those have to
be they have to go through with known as
match moving which is where some very
very careful people track the the motion
of the camera with some specialized
software that is not entirely automatic
unfortunately and there's a lot of
manual work to get that going and once
we have the camera then we can start
creating creatures and vehicles in
whatever kind of replacement or
enhancement that the shot requires and
those have to go through all the various
stages initially with modeling well
obviously concept art
from this note there's no concept
there's nothing to model but initially
modeling the then needs to be textured
at some point I can usually go in
parallel and eventually that goes into
the hands of riggers which is what I
used to be and those guys they are they
articulate and add controls for the
animators to use to bring it bring stuff
to life be a creature or a prop or an
awesome robot or whatever and and then
at the same time there's also occasional
enhancements fight well i should i say
occasionally not really there's a lot of
enhancements of simulations that happen
either water splashes explosions rocks
falling all kinds of stuff that the
effects department does in parallel
while everyone else is trying to do the
the creatures vehicles or props and then
eventually it all comes it comes
together with the help of the lighters
then the render farm or hybrid render
farm the part cloud part local and it
goes into the hands of the compositors
who then composite the final layers
together and make the beautiful
consistent look throughout the whole
thing and then that gets delivered to
the client and they they add music and
do the edit Wow so out of my experience
any like I've done some rendering of
videos and there's two problems with
that it takes forever and you end up
with huge files how do you make it
happen like I I mean I'm imagining that
to make it like a dragon look real
that's a lot of gigabytes in a lot of
processing how do you how do you make
these actually happen yeah well we have
a lot of storage on premise we i we have
a mix of different filers we have
acquired through the years and it's all
presented through a caching appliance
that we have as one common place for the
mount and its many hundreds of terabytes
it's it's really
intense and some of the stuff that we do
in the pipeline to try to to minimize
the duplication is like to do the
symlinks when stuff gets version but it
doesn't really change for example when
the textures get versioned again and
only like 11 bit of the somewhere on the
thing changed and we tried to symlink so
we don't have to copy so much data do
try to keep it light obviously not
always the case but we do where we can
and of course we use the we use the
cloud will do to be able to render
really massive massive things okay so
you're saying okay you mentioned that
you've got a lot of storage and cpu on
prem so where does where does the cloud
where does google cloud platform come in
yeah so we do a lot of different movies
at the same time a lot of different
shows we call them it could be like a
anything from like four to like a dozen
shows about in different stages of
production and from time to time they're
usually at the end of the week there
will be some kind of delivery to the
client because you deliver things as you
start to complete them or at least you
deliver semi-finished versions that look
better and better and it's very
important that those deadlines must
never ever ever be late those are set in
stone and you must deliver and so my my
wife's boss sauce other so the storm
coming so to speak and he knew that
about maybe leave a year and a half ago
two years ago he ec saw it coming that
we would get to the point where we just
didn't have enough hardware to make
everyone happy and it will come that we
will have a friday where we could not
actually deliver what we had to deliver
and we were just disappointed client
then be in a bad position and so he he
tasked me a long time ago to work in and
sort of an implementation that would
work together with our with our current
reniform software in such a way that is
relatively seamless for the the artist
because it just shows up as another
render node it's not its own separate
thing
it's not a whole other completely
isolated brand new system per se it's
part of it sort of comes as part of the
same network as the current farm so it
almost gets treated as if it was a
neighbor so to speak and then what
you're you're able to use that to expand
your capabilities and like sort of use
that elastic cloud to grow as you need
it yeah once we once we had it had
everything configured more or less right
you can very easily using we were using
the managed instance groups feature and
we had a come we have a few common
templates for different specs and
usually we do a different specs for
different shows depending on how much
they require and we we've been really we
use a lot the dinette the dynamic the
custom instance where you can drag drag
and drop the number of cores a number of
a month of r and s ever since I was that
was a an option we've been using it a
lot and we always use custom instances
because sometimes you don't really need
all that much ram but we need more cores
and i'm excited to say that the cloud
machines that the top of the cloud
machines are considerably better than
what we have on premise as it's a it's
an ongoing race I mean this the second
that we it's very expensive to do a
massive upgrade of whatever 200 notes
that we have locally and get them all to
like the latest specs and then they're
within a few months there's something
new and and having the cloud being able
to to burst so easily in a matter of
seconds you can launched hundreds of
machines and it's in it's so fast and so
effortless that it's a great thing to
have just when you really need to burst
and you need you need the resources to
to finish the computation of producing
those images we use a renderer core
called Arnold which was recently
acquired by Autodesk and we do most of
her work in odorless Maya and flexing
Houdini and compositing in nuke
so there's a soon as you start talk
about rendering printable machines came
to mine is this something that you use
or have you considered using it yes we
we actually do use them we don't use
them exclusively because at the moment
we it's up to the discretion of the
Wrangler which is the the person the
human being managing the farm or
overlooking the farm it's up to the
discretion how many machines should come
up depending on what our resources are
like we only have so many we have a fair
number of licenses but we only have so
many so sometimes we'll need a bit more
local and a bit more on cloud it all
depends it fluctuates a lot and it's
it's a hard task to do programmatically
so for now we need a human element of a
Wrangler to to make the call now that
said we do have scripts once the
machines come on and they they become
idle they start to die very quickly and
one of the we're one of the great things
with a google cloud is the permanent
billing I know there's a 10 minute
minimum but after that is per minute
then we we have a script that after the
second Idol minute the machine dies so
we really try not to waste any other
resources but to start them we at one
point we had we had given the artists
the ability to start their own machines
and they got a little crazy they would
start a very too many and I really
quickly realized that I had to be
overlooked by someone cool so you I'm
imagining that at any point you have a
decent amount of this a number of
machines running how do you make sure
that they all they all have the good
configuration how do you manage the
software install licenses and all that
stuff so just referred that I just
remember one thing about the pre-emptive
all's we do use them the reason the
thing is that we don't use them
exclusively because the well the way
that they work is they will die
eventually that without notice but we
well the Wrangler
is physically present in at work we will
try to use them as much as you can and
then when they leave for the night we
will do a switch and we'll start some
regular VMs that way we know that
there's going to be some VMS left just
to get so if they if they happen to shut
down while the person is looking they
can manually restart them yeah yeah or
the yeah basically that because they're
more likely to survive but as during the
day we use them as much as we can when
we use the club and so you go to go to
the next question the digital fast we
coordinate all the configuration with
saltstack don't know if you're familiar
with the technology can you can you
explain explain for every listener so if
for people who are honest familiar with
it yeah it's a it's a configuration and
deployment tool it's the core is written
in python and i like python so I like it
it's quite configurable in a really
really flexible and it has this very
straightforward I mean there's other
things like an ansible or or chef
they're similar I haven't tried many of
the others but i really like salt it's
very easy to configure it's all based on
gamal files which are very human
readable you can have conditional
templating and mostly multiple masters
if you want it's quite flexible and so
we so we have we actually use for
example we query some of the vm metadata
on the machine to configure itself so we
set some tags and some some and
basically when I'm live environment
variables some metadata variables and we
use those to for example configure which
show the the slave will be four and
that's that's using salt to read them at
the data to then configure the machine
on on first boot so like you're talking
about you the person who's working on
the show they can fire up machines and
they can then specify like hey I need
these resources and then salt will go
off and configure those resources for
them is that that's not about right yeah
basically we just a managed instance
groups
with the custom templates that we keep
we keep cloning a sort of the default
template we change a free attributes for
this de specs and what show what we have
a code name for each shell what code
name a will be four and then those
machines will launch given whatever
number you request of them they will
appear and they will begin taking jobs
from those shows cool so you've been
talking about how you have like an on
prem and the cloud like sort of shared
solution yeah how are you like I'm
guessing there's some assets that will
need to go like up and down like how is
that managed what sort of challenges if
you got there yeah so we initially we
tried stuff like are sinking and maybe
even SCP there which is not mad fast
it's it's very single threaded it works
but it's really not not fast and then we
started looking at options and there's a
few that are sort of flood via UDP to
maximize the the throughput but the one
that really took the cake for me was a
piece of stuff piece of technology from
the guys at CERN the supercollider
people they have a software called FDT
it's just a very originally called fast
data transfer and that's a it's made in
Java they don't provide the source it's
not technically open source but it is
free it is free to use and it's
incredibly fast you you can use it over
a VPN SSH tunnel or directly if you want
and basically it's a bit like aspera if
you if you know what that is a lot of
people use it in my industry but the
despair is very expensive f dt is the
same ideas as a flood of UDP packets
that maximize your pipe and it's
extremely concurrent there's a you can
start hundreds of threads with a bunch
of data and it all arrives at the same
time and it's it's it's so far the only
tool that we've seen that can really
like absolutely maximize our gigabit
pipe that we
have going to the Internet are you able
to share how fast you're able to get
some data transfers or things you may
have seen ah well we only have a gigabit
internet others to do at the moment and
we pretty much fill it up and we had
like eight to nine hundred megabit looks
like and and we had a few times whenever
when I was getting started with this
technology that I that uh I accidentally
choked the network and for a few seconds
we last internet because it was too fast
which I guess is a good problem to have
better than too slow cool um so now also
curious um I guess you probably work on
some relatively big budget and somewhat
secret type projects yeah what do you
have in terms of like security what sort
of considerations if you had that way to
make sure everything is not public to
the Internet probably in any way shape
or form yeah we tried to well we use the
google the Google cloud platform
firewall to pretty much block all access
except to the AIP from Montreal that's
one thing and we try to use VPN wherever
possible and we believe that's
reasonably secure so how how are using
VPN is that so the machines are on the
cloud are able to access the prime
storage or do you use it for some other
things we use it to for licensing for
licensing and to actually talk to the
farm software we use a software called
cube with a queue it's from a company
called pipeline effects it's it's quite
flexible we have used it for many years
now and we have customized a lot and
it's it's not rocket science it's
basically a queue manager and people
make make jobs they give it they give
them attributes to give them what what
cluster they should go for how much RAM
they should have and so on and and the
machines appear just the same as the
machines on on the local machines appear
the cloud ones are just in the same
place in the same interfaces I'm
everything so it's it's quite seamless
the only thing is that we
are having a an upload of the things
that are required by your scene file
which is like one extra job and we
require one extra download job so that
the files as a complete they get
downloaded back and we just have to t
for that and it's very very fast what is
the process for someone to be like oh we
have this scene that we need to process
right now very fast like do you have a
turbo button or something OS these are
like a bunch of instances something like
that we do not have a turbo button but
we we do basically when you submit a job
to the cloudy it's the same as
submitting a job locally the source of
checkboxes use the cloud lag and it just
configures a job differently it scans
for the dependencies of the thing that
you're rendering tries to find all the
terabytes worth of textures and models
and cameras and animations and puts it
in a big upload job through FTT and then
it's a Miss to the farm just as it would
be without the cloud cool so we're gonna
running out of time but is there
anything else that you would like to
mention or something that we had
forgotten so an interesting thing i
guess i'd like to mention is that we're
using gloucester FS for a server
solution in the cloud it's a open source
project that allows very very easy
distributed redundant storage across
multiple machines in this case we use
VMs and it's a way to get faster reads
than just one machine one disk and it
allows us to scale really easily it's
very easy to to add more they call it
brixmor sort of units of storage sort of
kind of like adding more disks and it
makes it very very easy and very fast
and it's it's open source it takes like
10 minutes to get started to do a your
own your first shared volume it's really
quite wonderful and I had to I had tried
when the very first time that I start on
the cloud I tried to see how fast could
I get just one machine with like an NFS
share that would be just shared a few
after to a few machines and I
after a few after something like 40
machines it was just too much it
couldn't take it and that wasn't
google's fault it's just NFS is really
not the way to go one when node cannot
store all your storage that's that's not
kind of not going to scale but now we
have a at the moment we have like six
storage nodes and they're all sharing
several terabytes worth and it's very
fast as comparable to what we have
locally out of curiosity you didn't use
Google Cloud storage because cluster f s
gives you some other capability or
something or what's the deal there well
we well we don't we didn't use the
there's a open source project to mount
the Google out storage but I that it's
not it's not of super stable or super
tested so we I did not trust trust it
for for serious production and cluster
just allows us to have a safe redundant
shared volume that something like NFS
will not be able to to give us and and
we we can't directly without mounting
without having something to mount the
Google Cloud storage we can't directly
use it so we we use it a sort of
veterans transitionary place or as a
place where backups and stuff like that
that's sir cool well um Alan thank you
so much for joining us that was really
interesting it so thank you the world of
VFX is something that I know nothing
about and so it's it's a it's a very
interesting figure to see behind the
curtain a little bit great yeah very
cool thank you so much thank you so
thanks again to Alan for such an
interesting interview I know the next
time I will go to the movies I will be
checking out is this ecs actually
rendered is this real it is pretty
amazing what they're able to do nowadays
yeah absolutely there's definitely a few
movies that they've worked on that now I
want to go say so that's pretty cool as
well awesome so why don't we get stuck
into the question of the week which
comes from the wonderful community
members from the Google cloud platform
slack channel we were talking about on
there the other day about say you have a
Google compute engine virtual machine
instance you have it up and running and
you think yourself oh I'd love to be
able to scale this so what I want to be
able to do is create an instance groups
which lets me scale that up and down
really easily is there a way that I can
create a
this group from and already running vm
so i actually had to do it is long time
ago for a demo which is actually open
source and we've talked about it before
it's called abellana and basically when
i was in the development phase of it i
created an instant and then installed
image magic on it any southern
imagemagick was actually couple like it
took me some time then i realized that
you could do sudo apt-get yeah whatever
but it took me some time to get the
whole environment said working out
working correctly and the next step is
like oh ok so now I want to have this
instance but just running more of them
yeah and it is actually quite simple if
you are in the development phase and you
can delete that instance it is pretty
simple you can delete the instance but
making making sure that you do not
delete the disk attached to it and then
you can create a new image from that
disk and now when you create your
instance template in the instant in the
manage instance group you can use that
new image that you just created so with
that you're good yeah that's that's not
too many bad jab steps that is pretty
simple so from from your instance with
the disc you delete the instance because
you need to to create a new image you
need a disc that is not attached to
anything yep so you first delete the the
instance without dealing the disc then
create an image and then from there the
template so if we have a vm that's
running and you still want to better
work on it though and you don't want to
delete it what do we do then so that is
where that is when it becomes a little
bit more complicated because basically
what you need to do is an extra step to
generate a disc that is not attached to
anything and to do that there's a little
trick that I didn't know about but you
told me which is create a snapshot from
the disc yep and then a disc from the
snapshot yep and then the rest is the
same rest is the same so you can create
your image you can get your instance
template and your way to go yep which is
it is actually pretty simple and that
way you you're able to go basically from
your prototype to something that
actually scales and you can do whatever
you
from it yeah yeah which is which is the
normal the normal development process
that i use the next step is normally oh
the so now that everything is already in
instances maybe i will use containers i
move container and gene and stuff like
that yeah but maybe you work on VMS
that's where you're at not certainly
cooled I saw you find yeah yeah that's
great awesome so thank you very much for
another episode Francesca are you going
to be anywhere exciting in the coming
weeks so not really i'm actually going
to stay in san francisco working on my
videos and working on a couple of things
that i want to do do we have some more
episodes of just for fun coming up there
so i published one and there's a couple
more that i'm editing right now and if
you have any ideas about things that you
would like to to have on that serious
send them my way I'm always curious
about it excellent what about you so I'm
gonna be kind of attending a couple of
conferences coming up actually I was
just a bit weird for me that's kind of
fun that's that feels good though when
you go to a conference that you have the
pressure of CQ yes so i'll be at pax dev
i'll be just attending that so hanging
out with a bunch of gamers which is
something I love to do and then I'll be
off to one of my favorite conferences
which is strange loop and st. Louis in
September looking at there's some on
session stuff I may end up doing it a
little bit of something there we'll see
we'll see how that goes but I'll
definitely be there that's not an event
I would miss out on very cool ah so we
have not done it in a while so maybe we
should remember our listeners how to get
in touch with us yes so there's a bunch
of ways to do it we have a web page yeah
it's gcp podcast.com or cloud.google.com
/ podcast good also we have an email
hello at gcp podcast we are on twitter
at gcb podcast on google + @ + gcb
podcast on dreaded @ / r / GP podcast
and finally we are also we have the
channel podcast on the Google cloud
platform community channel yeah
absolutely that's a mouthful it is a
little alright well yes thank you so
much again for joining me thank you and
thank you for thank you to all our
listeners
for being there yeah and see you all
next week yep talk to the old next week
you